[Music]
we both have kids your kids are older
than mine I have a younger children your
kids are owned and out I'm an empty
nester are they are they in show
business your kids so they my two
daughters are not in show business one
is a teacher in in East LA here she does
the urban education and then yes and the
other one is in pre-med in college and
my son my son is not is kind of you know
he's a semi-regular on a show called
scare tactic tactics he's an editor
he's uh he's a bogie bomb he does he's a
Renaissance man he's always trying to
make money in different ways in this
business sometimes not really on the one
know what he did what do you do this is
not funny I get a call from I love
anyone who starts the story with this is
not funny
no but this play I can't play I won't
let them down yeah anyway the he I got a
call from a production company from I
think P Diddy's production company
saying we wanted they want to rent out
my home for a video for a video shoot
out of nowhere and I said well I don't
number one
how'd you get my note I don't do that
why I don't rent out my house why me why
why why would you call me and they go
what we saw your your house online on a
video and we we like we like the
property I go but that's not my house
they go well look go to youtube and look
at ski lo burning up and I went and
looked it's my house and I found someone
shot a music video at your house I
didn't know my son said he was having a
party he actually rented out our house
it's not funny I said it's not funny
don't laugh and I go online I know that
you guys have like a piece of the video
I was telling the guy backstage we
actually have this is a clip this is the
video that I guess your son made you
didn't make the video he rented out the
house to the people that made the video
out your permission I didn't know I saw
this online I went that's a nice
property that's mine and then and then
look at the is from ski lo the burning
up is a sauce you know hello is it a car
hello
let's take a look let's see what what
this is that's my house these people
it's a full-blown video and is this from
your family let's talk to my daughter
where is your daughter that was my
daughter that's the one that's in
pre-med you know what no I don't want to
show it again don't go back don't go
back yeah that's incredible
ucomfy how did the neighbors not
complain how did all the neighbors
complained he said that they got calls
that there was a party at my house I go
to jam apart he didn't tell me was a
shoot he made a lot of money
my son is entrepreneurial his name is
Alex you can go see him on YouTube every
Thursday he does Alex Mandel really
encouraging this now no there is there
he is go check him out every Thursday
has a new YouTube